how are you doing sir I am very good I
am happy uh I am in the middle of
shooting which is great we were shooting
in in Spain in Valencia uh which was
very nice I had lovely Rices and and
wine over the weekends it was It was a
yeah it's it's beautiful to be shooting
with this team you know sure I want to
ask specifically in the footage that we
saw yeah there seems to be like uh that
you're going undercover in season two
you're sharp I was like I get credit to
Maggie you did it yeah Maggie
my God you were Maggie
I'm so glad to meet you thank you for
all the lovely things you said about the
show and all the support you gave us I
appreciate that very much yeah
he was it was very nice to to follow
your your uh how do you say
um
no emotional that your excitement for
the show it meant a lot to us yeah so
getting back to the sorry it's fine I'm
Maggie's gonna be very happy now I want
she should be she should be because we
do we do get to read you I mean oh no
Tony's made it very clear yeah but I
want to know so season two footage we
see what appears to be undercover doing
missions what can you say about that yes
I mean the first season ends with a guy
saying okay kill me or take me in but he
doesn't know what he's getting into it
no he doesn't speak the language and now
it's about becoming a spy you know we
have to we have to get to the point
where where he uh is where he goes in
this mission that that Rogue one starts
with so he has to become a real spy and
he's gonna have to learn a lot
uh you are halfway through the season
yeah I'm assuming you've read have you
read all 12 scripts oh of course right
so what what well not all 12 no yes but
yes you know where it's all going yes
it's everything how how I think for a
lot of fans one of the reasons why Andor
is so spectacular is the writing the
writing is just on another level can you
talk about the the writing of season two
and what has impressed you or made you
really happy
it takes it takes risks you know we're
not repeating what happened in season
one uh structurally it has changed you
know now we each block is a year and
then there's a there's a jump you know
between each block sure yeah and there's
a lot that you'll see and a lot that you
won't see and uh and it's quite
interesting you know it's risky uh and
it's gonna be challenging for audiences
in a good way uh Tony
Tony keeps raising the bar you know and
and that's the beautiful thing of
working with someone that uh cares so
much about what he does uh I would say
that it brings the best out of everyone
around you know uh when with good
writing everything starts with the
writing and with good writing you can
just get great people great ideas and
then a beautiful process uh it's been
fun it's just sad every day you know
because you know it's
when when they less you know of of this
journey that has been fantastic
um anyway yeah I have to rap with you
but right before you go yes what's it
been like working with K2 again
what excuse me what was that question I
think it has to do with a robot friend
I don't know what you're talking about I
I mean I think you're in the wrong the
wrong press lines you're talking about I
mean tell me where where are you getting
your information from Mr Gilroy actually
told me he said that you were going to
talk all about K2 in and or season two I
don't know what you're talking about
well I don't know what you're talking
about
I'm gonna pass you this